hagamos más ejercicios con la ecuación
del gas ideal tenemos presión por
volumen es igual al número de moléculas
que tenemos en moles por la constante
del gas ideal por la temperatura en
kelvin tengo un comentario que hacer
pues esto tiene sentido excepto por el
hecho de que r r esta misteriosa
constante
déjenme reacomodar primero la ecuación
presión por volumen es igual a r
por tnt habíamos establecido espero lo
recuerden que la presión por el volumen
debe ser proporcional esencialmente a la
energía total que hay en el sistema
temperatura esa energía promedio o
energía por molécula y este es el número
de moléculas que tenemos bloque r la
constante del gas ideal lo que hace es
que cuando multiplicamos moles por
kelvin de este lado la presión por
volumen es fuerza por área por volumen
es decir fuerza por unidad de distancia
también llamado jules entonces lo que
hace la constante del gas ideal
esencialmente es convertir hacer que
todo esto sea proporcional se tiene que
fijar una constante para tener las
unidades correctas así que la constante
r nos ayuda a pasar de un mundo donde
hay moles y kelvin
en el que se trabaja con bueno en este
caso atmósferas y litros o bari metros
cúbicos o kilopascales y metros cúbicos
pero sin importar qué unidades de
presión o volumen sean presión por
volumen siempre será jules así que r es
una traducción entre ambos mundos para
que todo sea proporcional con eso dicho
hagamos más problemas
digamos que tenemos digamos que queremos
saber cuántos gramos de oxígeno o2
cuántos gramos de o2 tenemos en 300
mililitros un contenedor de 300
mililitros con una presión de 12
atmósferas y una temperatura de 10
grados celsius ahora usamos como ya lo
hemos hecho nuestra ecuación del gas
ideal así que veamos presión es de 12
atmósferas 12 vamos a escribir unidades
atmósferas por el volumen el volumen
debería estar en litros esto es 300
mililitros que al dividirlo entre mil 1
litro es igual a mil mililitros es igual
a punto 3 litros
por punto tres litros
esto es igual al número de moles
y es aquí donde tenemos que prestar
atención porque si tenemos el número de
moles tenemos el número de gramos
entonces es igual a n por r pero que
erre usaremos si estamos trabajando con
atmósferas y litros usaremos esta verdad
litro atmósfera por mol kevin punto 0 82
por nuestra temperatura es de 10 grados
celsius que es igual a 283 kelvin ya que
tenemos esto dicho dividimos ambos lados
de la ecuación por esto de aquí nos
queda n es igual a 12 atmósferas estoy
invirtiendo la ecuación por punto 3
litros / punto 0 82 por 283 la respuesta
debe estar en moldes si quieren
verificar lo pueden hacer un estudio de
unidades incluyendo las de la constante
del gas ideal
el número de moles que buscamos tenemos
por punto 3
en 3.0 82 / 283 y esto es igual a punto
155 moles es igual a punto 155 moles
ahora cuántos gramos hay en un molde
oxígeno un molde oxígeno molecular
un modo de o2 todos sabemos que la masa
atómica del oxígeno es 16 una molécula
de oxígeno gaseoso tiene dos átomos
entonces tiene una masa atómica de 32
unidades 32 unidades de masa atómica su
masa por molécula es de 32 gramos
nosotros no tenemos un mol
tenemos puntos 155 moles para obtener
los gramos tenemos que multiplicar 32
gramos por mol
por morir
gramos por mor y esto por punto 155
moles entonces 32
por 155 es igual a 4.96 gramos o lo
podemos redondear a 5 gramos entonces
tenemos aproximadamente 5 gramos de
oxígeno molecular